la troupe de cendres
c'est bien peu libre et le dépose à les
attend pour les tendances maintenant
quelques encouragements et un maximum de
conseils techniques depuis le sol
eric bazeilles surveille chaque figure
réalisée par ses pilotes dans le ciel de
châteauroux tout nouveau renversement
déclenché verticale il faut corriger la
moindre petite erreur
celui qui fait une petite erreur de 5
degrés est bon il peut encore accéder au
podium et messi ont fait lors de 10
degrés sur sur un ou deux programmes ça
y est c'est fini on perd le podium ça
c'est sûr on perd un point par 5° donc
c'est très précis un grand ça tourne
l'avion retourne à 4 120 degrés secondes
sa fin tout le moins en moins d'une
seconde donc c'est très rapide au sol
comme dans les airs cette semaine à
châteauroux l'équipe de france prend le
temps de finaliser sa préparation en
débriefing seul face à la vidéo de son
vol
aude lemordant championne du monde en
titre analyse sa performance avec deux
sessions d'entraînement par jour
elle prend ses marques pour la
compétition fin août c'est un petit peu
des repères des images et puis un
constat milliards is un peu avec le
terrain ce qui fait que on est quand
même un peu plus que j'allais square
environ à la maison quoi ça fait une
grosse différence faire la différence
c'est justement l'objectif des 10
pilotes militaires et civils de l'équipe
de france devant leur public
pas question de laisser filer les
médailles aux concurrents russes et
américains chez les hommes les femmes et
par équipes
la france domine et veut tout gagner
l'équipe de france a remporté en 2013 le
titre mondial
donc on va essayer de reconquérir chez
nous ce titre là donc on y met tout
notre coeur et notre envie pour pouvoir
et bien reconquérir ce titre en voltige
aérienne
les derniers championnats du monde
organisés en france remonte à l'année
2000 sur le tarmac de châteauroux du 20
au 29 août prochain
les 60 meilleurs pilotes du monde seront
présents sensations fortes garanties